stuart mclean's world came crashing down
eight years ago he discovered then
that he had been infected with hepatitis
c when he was
just a child after he was wrongly
diagnosed with hemophilia
one of the thousands of victims of the
infected blood scandal
this has been a hard hard road finding
out
what they did to people and to myself
it's been
it's been like a no your worst nightmare
times ten
you know you every time you go to the
hospital you think
this is gonna be it where they tell me
i've got liver cancer
or some other heptatic disease
and you just it's a hard
hard life to live please state your full
name
a public inquiry is investigating how
people like stewart became infected
with contaminated blood products in the
nineteen seventies and eighties
no government has accepted
responsibility and the victims
have never been compensated but now the
government
has said it will redress disparity in
financial support schemes
that have seen victims in one uk region
receiving much
less than those living somewhere else
if i die now i know my wife will be
looked after
so for me that was very important very
important
because i never know how long he got
with pepsi
pete bernie died from cancer in 2019
after years of battling infected blood
related illnesses
it's been quite hard very hard with
pandemic as well i've needed
to see my family i needed to have the
hopes the changes mean bereaved
partners like christine will now
automatically get the same as
widows in other uk nations what we've
been through
is last year losing p and he campaigned
very hard and i just hope
they see it through
even if they just admit liability
stuart and christine have cautiously
welcomed the new measures
but stress they do not include everyone
they want an independent review for
compensation
also announced today to bring justice
for all
but no it will be too late for the many
who have died waiting ashish joshi sky
news
in seven oaks